hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play Hello Kitty
online
alright I've been wanting to play this
game for a while because you guys have
been suggesting it to me over and over
again so we've already made our
character here so let's just come
forward Oh looky we're on the magical
realm if you wanted to join me my name
is gonna be markiplier and and I want I
want this to be a perfect adventure for
all of us so if you want to join me -
feel free to hop in the game at any
point you know III don't mind you all
playing this game here because this is
gonna be a fun-filled adventure of love
and happiness in and acceptance for
everything we don't need we don't we
don't need so here we are we're starting
out on Oh
we've moved okay alright you can see
that we're playing this magical
adventure it's it's it's so lovely and
everything that we're doing here and I
I'm so happy that we can be together I
am fast thank you okay so as we can tell
we're going to various dream rooms here
there doesn't seem to be anybody else
and joy join joining us right now but
there could be a lot more things it
looks like melody has a quest here let's
just give it a try let's give it a try
okay it's okay it's okay love happiness
acceptance happiness love and happiness
and acceptance
acceptance okay here we are we're back
where we originally were before do
Daniel do Daniel did Daniel do Daniel
dear Daniel do huh dear Daniel dear
Daniel Andres welcomes you suggest speak
to the policeman wait a minute wait a
minute
there's something over here there's
something here there's something here
[Music]
[Music]